hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again and today
we have some early access game played
courtesy of Ubisoft so Thank You Ubisoft
for sponsoring this video they gave me
some early access to show off the new
season 9 hero black prior as well as the
new map and the new dominium ephra
season I called Harbor just case you
guys aren't aware season 9 will be
starting on January 31st it will be
coming with the new map which will show
on a second called harbor I have a few
other things to get into with the video
but first off like to be if you do enjoy
and let's get started with today's video
hey guys this is the new map harbor I
thought I'd shot the attacker side since
I like this the most get stabbed in the
stomach and then gets hung by his foot I
think it's pretty good and the sword is
still stuck in him which is pretty nice
but going back to what I talked about
before and that basically is is that
like I said season 9 is gonna be
starting January 31st and you're gonna
be getting the new hero black prior
which is obviously the gameplay with the
new map Harbor which is the map
currently right now I'll show I'll
showcase a little bit of it farther into
this video but on top of that we can
also do is get instant and early access
to the Vorta go hero prior and on top of
that you get also instant early access
to the other characters from season 10
11 and 12 by getting the year 3 season
pass it's gonna be $30 I believe it's
$30 the u.s. I'm not really sure what
its Canadian and stuff like that but
still a solid price I think it's one of
the better versions and the better you
know a better reasoning I personally
don't like spending steal to get new
characters I always like to buy the year
pass so I definitely recommend doing
that and with that like I said you get
plot you get 7 days early access so in
this case you'll be getting black prior
on the 31st and everyone will be getting
in who doesn't have to pass on the 7th
of the 8th which is pretty nice on top
of that you'll also get an elite outfit
for each hero 30 days of Champions that
is scavenger crates and an exclusive emo
or exclusive effect on the emotes which
I believe is the Thunderbolt in
frightening it looks really nice so yeah
you get the year 3 pass right now it's
on the Xbox Store PlayStation Store game
store all that stuff so you just get it
right now I definitely recommend getting
it it's the it's the better version than
just using your steel until want to save
that steel for executions in alpha
and stuff and I have to waste all of it
see if I can fight this guy it's get
thee out of garden move here
yeap hey bud yeah this is the new map
Harbor honestly I love this map a lot I
also try to show case the default feets
if I can all right that's fine yeah hit
me okay nope I missed all right that's
fine that right there is the zone attack
this little shield bash whoop it's
pretty nice it doesn't actually do
damage more stamina damage as you as you
saw the before or the Blackfyre has to
shield bashes the neutral one which is
that and then the heavy faint if shinobi
would stop the heavy faint one which is
more similar to ones that we've known
before with like conquer and whatnot so
that's really nice to see the first feat
is which I believe I may have used by
accident oh no I have the feet right now
okay that's good it came back so it is a
pretty interesting feat I think I'm
actually gonna get a little bit more
health for this so that I don't die well
basically what the speed does is that it
sacrifices your own health points to
give your teammates shield which i think
is really cool so if it is he's more of
a passive hero the second feat which is
what I'll actually be using right now in
bulwark stance which is this full block
I will be able to actually heal up which
is really nice and with this full block
you do two moves the unblockable heavy
which can be fainted if you want to or
you can do the scoop move which is
honestly my favorite one if I could pull
this off big scoop unblockable heavy 30
solid damage really good move it all you
have to do is instead of parrying oh
that's all you have to do is just press
the right bumper wall in full block and
it will do that move you can't just do
it normally they have to be throwing the
mover it looks really stupid you can't
actually land it this shinobi just keeps
throwing this move thank you we actually
hope oh my god we have all my feet sorry
oh my god I'm losing track here so the
third feet is this one with the broken
shield if you throw it onto an opponent
they can't any shields that they have
currently on they get taken away and it
prevents them from any more shows in the
future for a thing it's like a couple
seconds there's nothing too crazy well
the fourth feat favor one everyone
within the area gets a
and it keeps blinking white which is why
I could see the greet the green little
thing pulsating so if a teammate is at
sea and I'm a bee I pop this and then I
run all the way over to him I can still
get my entire team they don't have to be
right next to me it's not a one single
activation it's like a pulse and it
comes about three times I believe so you
can end up actually getting your entire
team shield which is really useful we
seem to be destroying this bot team
right now I'm gonna give my teammate
some help here
excuse me minions his top-heavy the -
forward heavy which is this move all
also has a counter it also is a crushing
counter property since he has dodge
block if you which means if you dodge in
any direction your guard will be that
direction so if you look I'm in the
right dodge the left now it's blocking
left dodge forward blocking top stuff
like that well he has the only - - movie
has is the shield bash but he also has a
- forward which is that move and if
someone throws a move from the top you
can actually crush and counter it which
is really interesting so I could pull it
off without screwing it up I have three
of them next to me so this one might be
a little bit hard to perform all right
let me let me actually get it let me get
rid of this arm usha so that I know I
can I could at least handle the shinobi
myself
oh I messed up come on throw the move
doodoo for the video do for the video
alright I don't want to do it on that
type move I just want him to do like a
like a top-heavy from neutral that's
kind of what I wanted alright this isn't
going exactly as I planned
now we have two ninjas on me alright
well this is fun
I'm glad we had this experience together
alright let me rush them real quick I'll
see if I can pull it off I don't even
know if it does even more damage than
the others I just know that it's a thing
it's really cool there it is
yes it was 20 damage but the normal
version does I can do it excuse me yeah
the normal version does 20 so there's a
little bit to it I would say it's style
points quick notes on the shield bash
which is the one from neutral the heavy
faint one stuff like that he actually
cannot wall supply it with these so do
be aware you won't get well not
forgetting any wall supply capabilities
and extra punishes from doing these
shield bashes you only just be hitting
them into the wall they actually don't
like flop onto it they just go near it
which is really interesting and neither
it does the zone attack the zone attack
also does not splash so that's that's a
very interesting to see as you could
tell I saw I whipped our Musha right
into it and nothing happened I'm gonna
get killed by my own teammate this is
gonna be on dude PK killed me bro come
on so close all we have to do is kill
them one time just one more and that's
it and you're ruining it yeah I spy
really like harbor I think that this map
is really nice it's a Dominion map big
dominion fan and it's also short so it's
a lot of big engagements and big
teamfights this would be a really nice
map to show in the future hey guys that
[ __ ] was pretty damn cool definitely
loving the new harbor map I'm very
excited to play the new season 9 hero
black prior as always just some quick
bit tidbits of info if you do want to
get the season 9 here as well as the
other heroes you do have to buy the year
3 season pass you don't actually have to
buy it but I believe it is the best
option so you don't have to pay any
game steal and you can play the
characters one week early before anyone
else that doesn't have the pass as well
like I talked about it comes with 30 a
champion status scavenger crate
exclusive effect on the emotes and it
would lead outfit let me know what you
guys think about the new black prior
hero how he how he plays you think he's
gonna be a pretty good character I think
he's gonna be solid in the 4v4 modes
maybe not so much in duels but yeah guys
like the VP do enjoy subscriber for new
I covered the informational side of
foreigner that being balanced changes
here are updates patch notes leaks so if
you want to be kept up today with
everything happening in the world of for
honor so you never miss out definitely
subscribe to the channel with that guys
they guys for watching the video and
peace out
[Music]